I did it's fun following you on
Instagram and I enjoy it just guns and
[__]
yeah it started off like a bucket list
man it was like all the things that I
want to do when I was younger I just
said because I made a lot of money in
like 2013-14 right that's from poker
yeah so I'd like kind of struggle to
climb the ladder and then I find my like
found my Niche which is what I always
knew that I was gonna find which was
like the [__] Super Rich billionaire
guys and when I got into those games it
was like [__] Wheels came off the
wagon you know like 10 million wins in a
night 12 million you know crazy [__]
right yeah and so like it was like grind
grind grind grind grind like all of a
sudden like knock it out of the park and
with less effort like worse players less
risk but it was [__] bigger money you
know I was like
still got a risk to win you know like
you gotta bet 5 million to win 5 million
so it's like you know it's a [__] it
was a lot of stress but that always was
where I knew I was going to end up like
I wasn't trying to be like one of these
[__] collecting bracelets playing
online like showing everybody how
[__] good I was I was you know want
to be perceived as a trust fund idiot
that didn't know how to play the gun
with the all these [__] you know like
producers and celebrities and eventually
like we were playing so big that the
celebrities couldn't afford it the
[__] producers couldn't you know what
I mean that was like this crazy thing
where it's like rare air you know were
you in that uh Molly's game yeah the
Molly's game yeah I actually wrote the
first chapter of her book wow so yeah
yeah she's it was funny man that that
movie like so accurately depicted her
nice it was it was scary how like spot
on it was but yeah now our game was a
real thing and it was like yeah I
remember that Bradley Ruderman guy came
in he lost like 25 million bucks
and uh I got a little bit of it
um I actually had to so I got I won 85
000 and I had to write a check for 100
grand to get the 85.
um
and then I think she like or wait no
sorry they gave me a check for a hundred
I paid her 15 000 in cash for my 85 win
and then when they came after me they
came after me for the hundred so they
came after me for more than I even
[__] won and they didn't just win it
from him it's like a ring game but he
was like one of the losers so I ended up
getting a check from him I don't even
know if I beat him for any money but so
I had to pay that back and then I'd pay
like Nick cassavetes money back I mean
just just to put this in perspective
this would be like
if somebody [__] robbed the bank and
went into a [__] convenience store
and bought a candy bar and ate it and
then went and bought a suit and [__]
wore it and then they go back to the
[__] tailor and the [__] store
owner and like oh you should have known
this guy [__] got his money illegally
like give the money back
right no [__] you know just like
if I had lost in the game they're not
gonna give me my money back you know so
it's like the worst free roll of all
time right did you have a character in
that movie or no no I asked her to like
stay out of it at the time I was like
because I was playing in like 2011 when
she was writing this book and this was
before like Instagram all this [__] and
like nobody knew what the [__] it was
and I was kind of like trying to stay
under the radar at the time
um so yeah do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now
yeah dude